ده شيء تطورات المتلاحقه المرتبطه بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا بان تلك الحرب مقبله
على مرحله جديده قد تشهد تغيرا في تكتيكات
القتال على محاور الجبهه الشرقيه يحاول
الجيش الروسي مسندا بمليشيات فاجنر
والقوات الانفصاليه الماليه له تحقيق تقدم
حاسم في اقليم دونباس خلال الاسابيع
المتبقيه من فصل الشتاء والى الجنوب يواصل
الكريم بحسب تقارير غربيه تعبئه قوته في
شبه جزيره القرم ويرسلوا تعزيزات عسكريه
جديده الى قوته الموجوده عند الضفه
الشرقيه من مها الدين برو في مقاطعه خرسون
وذلك في الوقت الذي يسعى فيها الروس بحسب
تلك التقرير لتصعيد الحرب بحلول هجوم
الربيع المقبل باستخدام الطائرات المسيره
والمدفعيه والطائرات الحربيه والدبابات
اما الجانب الاوكراني الذي يطالبه حلفاؤه
الغربيون بالتعديل تكتكاتها القتاليه
فيراعاهن على ان تزويده بدبابات ثقيله من
طراز شالنجر وابرمز ولبرد اثنين سيحدث
تحولا حاسما لمصلحته في مسار الحرب تشير
وتقديرات المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه الى انه اذا حصل كياف على
100 دبابه في الاجمال فسيكون تاثيرها
كبيرا في ساحه القتال ضد روس ويعتقد خبراء
عسكريون النبي مقدور الدبابات الغربيه ان
شاء قدره هجوميه تخترق الدفاعات الروسيه
وتضع حدا لحرب الخنادق الطويله ينضم الينا
من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بك عميد حنا عميد حنا
هل ترى ان هنالك مؤشرات على تغيير
التكتيكات من قبل التكتيكات الحربيه على
ارض المعركه من قبل روسيا واوكرانيا ايضا
بالطبع كده المرحله القادمه هي مرحله هجوم
هجوم يعني الفريقان يستعدان لمرحله هجوم
الرئيس بوتين يريد بالحد الادنى استرداد
ما تبقى من دنيا اتسكولوجيا ويبقى موضوع
خرسان لانه عامل النهر هو حاجز طبيعي
واليوم الاستعداد لاوكراني هو استعداد
للهجوم تتحدث عن الدبابات
نتحدث عن الاليات المدرعه نتحدث عن
المسطحات ناقلات الجند المدرعه المدفعيه
الدفاعات الجويه وكاننا نرى منظومه ليست
جاهزه حتى الان فداء ولكن نتحدث عن منظومه
قابله للخلق ولكن يبقى السؤال الاساسي
فداء اليوم المتطلبات الميدانيه والوسائل
المطلوبه للاوكرانيين كبيره جدا مع
امكانيات قليله فاذن يجب ان يكون هناك
تعويض في القوى يعني تثبيت الجيش الروسي
في مكان والهجوم في المكان الاضعف من هنا
اقتراح او اا نصيحه الغرب بالتخلي عن
محمود والتركيز على المنطقه الجنوبيه او
على جسر البري كما ورد في التقرير طيب
تركيزه على الجنوب اي افضل لي يعطي للجانب
الاوكراني من الناحيه العسكريه
اذا اعتبرنا ان الهجوم يبدا على محور
زبارود جامليتو بول هذا الامر قد يهدد
الجسر البري ماريو بول وبالتالي عزل
القوات الروسيه الموجوده على الضفه
الشرقيه لنهار خيرسون بعد الانسحاب
وبالتالي الوصول الى مرحله الهجوم على
جزيره شبه جزيره القرم ولكن هذا في الحديث
هذه في الامان هذه في المكتوب والتخطيط
ولكن يبقى الاستعداد الوسائل العباد
البشري من هنا نرى كده انه همم الجيش
الروسي يصطبق هذه الامور بالتشديد على
منطقه اوريكي بقول يا بول وهي منطقه ليست
بعيده تقريبا 50 كلم عن زبارودها وكانه
يقوم بعمليه استيعاب عمليه استقباق
وبالتالي تحديد مركز خط معين لانه من ينظر
الى الخريطه الى مدينه
بول يعرف انها محور اساسي باتجاه الشرق
باتجاه خرسون وباتجاه شبه جزيره القرم
الاعمده الياس حالنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا لكم انت معنا من بيروت